- I always like to close up the show
with something cool and interesting
I find on social media.
I think might bring y'all joy,
but this week we've turned the tables
and we're showing moments on the show
that have gone the most viral.
So instead of what I'm liking,
this is what you're liking.
(audience cheers)
Okay, so it's time to reveal
the last one on the list.
Basically, it's just me
and Sandra Bullock being
ridiculous together.
Take a look.
Is it true that your kids
have a talent for singing?
They love singing?
- My daughter does.
She has some pipes.
- That's exciting.
- So you know they say skips a-
my parents were opera singers.
- I was gonna say your
parents are singers.
- I cannot sing at all. My
parents were singers, both dead.
It's okay.
- But they were singers,
though, okay, but that's cool.
Wait you don't sing?
- That they're dead or that their singers?
- No, that they're singers.
That's so sad that they're dead.
I'm sweating.
Oh my God's it's worst date ever.
Okay. So wait.
No, no, no.
No.
That's so sad.
- So my parents are dead,
Then you say, "Oh my God that's so sad."
- No that's so no, that is sad.
- Yeah, yeah.
- But it's super cool they were
singers cause I'm a singer.
(laughing)
- So wait, but speaking
you said you don't like doing
furniture and stuff like that.
But do you like DJ?
(laughing)
Jesus.
- Wiki wiki wiki.
- Then do you
- Wiki. Wiki.
- No, do you DJ or do you
decorate for Christmas?
- Did you just call me a whore?
- No.
(both laughing)
Honest to God like
it's uncanny
how close to like my friends you are.
- Your friends are whores as well?
- Yes.
- All of my friends are whores, okay.
Like I'm fine.
- You're fine. Everything's fine.
I've got makeup under my nails.
Oh, love makeup.